[Applause]
[Music]
it's a new releases special delivery
typically on this show we run down some
of the hottest games coming to all
platforms each week but right now we've
got a special sponsored episode thanks
to PlayStation stores totally digital
sale you won't find any of these at a
retail store but you will find them in
the PlayStation Store over the next few
weeks let's jump right into the first
batch of games the first thing you'll
notice about the sorts of ditto is how
adorable the art is second you'll die
pretty quickly but that's ok
every time one hero falls and new one
Rises and you can loot the corpse of the
previous adventurer for their items and
weapons
these range from the typical swords and
bows to Goofy weapons like a frisbee and
magical golf club you can also find
stickers to give your heroes special
perks you can traverse the overworld
conquer dungeons go on side quests and
stop the evil normal all by yourself or
with a friend in coop the swords of
ditto is available now and now for
something a lot less cutesy and a lot
more steampunk if you've ever wanted to
be an air pirate guns of Icarus Alliance
might just be what you're looking for
it's all about airship on airship combat
with up to four players Manning each
vessel you can take on the role of pilot
gunner or engineer steering your ship
through the air gunning down opponents
or repairing the ships battle damaged
ships are customizable to letting you
create a small quick moving charger or a
massive dreadnought with six different
factions battling for control of the
skies every battle has the potential to
reshape the world from above guns of
Icarus Alliance will be available from
Tuesday May 1st
if you'd rather race ships than battle
them there's Trailblazers but you still
need to work together with your team
here to see each side can paint the
track with their team color and you can
boost over your own color to shoot ahead
of your opponents the more paint you lay
down the faster your team will zip
around the track and because paint can
be dropped anywhere no two races are
ever the same the more stylish Lee you
race the more points will gain - you can
team up for a three-on-three race online
with up to 6 players or play locally via
split-screen Trailblazers will be
available from Tuesday
and those are some of the hottest
totally digital games will be playing
over the next few weeks regular episodes
of new releases go live every Sunday so
stay tuned for more great games you'll
want to pick up thanks for watching guys
and we'll be back with a second episode
of a special delivery very soon